[Musik]
o Mar
1993 ich habe den Vatikan zum ersten Mal
am 9 märz 1993 betreten was für ein
nervenketzel ein großer nervenketzel
denn ich habe zwar immer meine Kunden
besucht auch institutionelle Kunden aber
für einen Katholiken ist das etwas
Besonderes etwas sehr
[Musik]
aufregendes alle meine Freunde wussten
dass ich seit vielen Jahren als Manager
tätig war und wenn sie mich sahen
nannten sie mich immer den Bankier
Gottes banchiere
Dio das war natürlich ein geistreicher
Scherz für den ich heute leider auf
wirklich brutale Weise bezahlen muss ja
da bin ich
nun mea Kulpa Korruption im
[Musik]
Vatikan kann ich es abnehmen
danke
es ist so real denn gestern bis 2
Minuten nach Uhr hatte ich das Gefühl
ein Freund des Papstes zu sein ein
treuer Gefolgsmann des Papstes und dann
steht der Papst hier und sagt mir dass
er mir nicht mehr
vertraut wahrscheinlich konnte der Papst
nicht ahnen was für Skandale eine
Untersuchung über den Erwerb eines
großen Gebäudes im Zentrum Londons
auslösen könnte es handelt sich um den
schwerstenan der Letten 30 Jahre im
vakan es ist eine Art Vati Gate bei dem
franziskus beschlossen hat zumindest
scheinbar niemandem gegenüber
Rechenschaft
abzulegen es ist ein Skandal sie haben
Dinge getan die nicht anständig
waren
ich lese jeden Tag das Bulletin das der
Heilige Stuhl auf seiner Website
veröffentlicht Anfang Oktober 2019 stand
dort in drei Zeilen ganz lapidar dass
die vatikanische Gendarmerie eine Reihe
von Durchsuchungen im Büro des
staatssekretariats durchgeführt hat da
es sich um das Büro handelt das dem
Papst am nächsten steht konnten wir
erkennen dass eine erschütternde
Untersuchung begonnen hatte und dass
eine solche Aktion im Vatikan
offensichtlich nicht ohne die Billigung
und gen
en wer
konte es war der interne Prüfer der
sagte dass hier etwas Schlimmes
vorlag er kam zu mir und ich fragte ihn
ob er sich sicher sei er zeigte mir die
Zahlen und fragte mich was er tun
solle dafür ist die vatikanische Justiz
zuständig geh und melde es den Promotor
der
Justiz der Promoter der Justiz bat mich
um die Erlaubnis für die Durchsuchungen
es bestand der Verdacht der Korruption
und in diesen Fällen sagte er müsse er
dieses Büro durchsuchen dieses Büro also
unterschrieb ich die
[Musik]
Genehmigung wir erer ist eine Geschichte
die sich im operativen Herzen des
Vatikans abspielt in dem dem Papst am
nächsten stehenden Ministerium dem
Staatssekretariat das bis in die Schweiz
hineinreicht um diese komplizierte
Geschichte verständlicher zu gestalten
haben wir beschlossen einiges Szenen mit
Schauspielern nachzustellen im
Mittelpunkt der Ermittlungen steht eine
Handvoll Finanziers und hochrangiger
prelaten die von der vatikanischen
Justiz verdächtigt werden einen
Kriminellen Plan zur Plünderung der
vatikanischen Staatskasse ausgehckt zu
haben
[Musik]
or ich habe einen Anruf vom
Staatssekretariat erhalten Monsignor
Angelo beo wollte mit mir sprechen um
mich mit einer bestimmten Aufgabe zu
betrauen er sagte mir hören Sie ich habe
einen sehr guten Freund der die Rechte
an einem Ölfeld in Angola besitzt damals
war die Rede V größten jemals in Afrika
entdeckten Ölfeld etwa 180 000 Barrel
pro Tag etwas riesiges Förderungen für
Jahre sie baten mich um eine
Stellungnahme für mich war das ein
absolutes Novum denn ich war
ausschließlich im Finanzbereich
tätig wir haben in LAN
getofen eine zentrale Figur in dieser
Untersuchung die seit Monaten das
Interesse der großen nationalen
Zeitungen auf sich zieht und wieder
einmal wirft sie ein schlechtes Licht
auf den tessina Finanzplatz kasso ist
seit über 20 Jahren externer Fondmanager
des staatssekretariats im Auftrag
mehrerer Banken zuletzt für die
kreditswis im Jahr 2014 zog er von Rom
nach Lugano um seine eigene
Treuhandgesellschaft zur genel zu
eröffnen der ehemalige bker hat sich
bereit erklärt uns in einem
ausführlichen Interview seine sich der
Dinge zu
schildern das ist eine treuhandurkunde
ein paar golfpokale hier und da ich habe
den Rotary Pokal
gewonnen die Geschichte begann im Jahr
2013 als Monsignor beo ihn wegen einer
Investition im Ölsektor
kontaktierte den Wert dieses Geschäfts
schätzen aber war eine Investition in Öl
ethisch
vertretbar das ist eine gute Frage aber
wenn eine Institution einen
investitionsvorschlag hat gehe ich davon
aus dass dieser Aspekt von ihrer Seite
aus bereits geprüft und berücksichtigt
worden
ist wie viel hat der Vatikan investieren
sollen sie sprachen von 200 Millionen
dollarel der Schöpfer dieser Investition
bekleidete damals das Amt des
Stellvertreters für Allgemeine
Angelegenheiten das heißt des
Stellvertreters des Leiters des
staatssekretariats Kardinal parolin er
war der dritte in der Hierarchie des
[Musik]
Vatikans das Staatssekretariat verfügt
über eine Staatskasse von 650 Millionen
Euro die sich zu einem Drittel aus einem
Fond dem sogenannten Paul dem Fond und
zu zwe Drittel aus
des Petrus Dienstes
speist der peterspfennig der etwa 400
Millionen Euro wert ist stammt
stattdessen aus allen Almosen die dem
Papst von den Gläubigen aus aller Welt
direkt gespendet
werden das Staatssekretariat sollte das
Geld aus dem peterspfennig für die
Unterstützung der ärmsten verwenden auch
für die Verwaltung der
Weltkirche
der peterspfennig ist quasi so wie eine
riesige almosenbüchse in einer
Kirche ist im Grunde eine Art
Geldautomat und der ist
wichtig ihen steht dadurch stets
frisches Geld zur Verfügung dass sie
investieren können und das nicht von
vornherein einer Kontrolle durch den ior
unterliegt aus dem peterspfennig der aus
den Spenden der Gläubigen an den Papst
stand und zur Unterstützung der Kirche
und der Ärmsten der Armen bestimmt ist
in eine Ölquelle in Angola investiert
werden
soll für die päpstlichen Richter ist
dies das erste Verbrechen das ihnen
vorgeworfen wird die Zweckentfremdung
von Geldern die für wohltätige Zwecke
bestimmt waren für eine spektakuläre
Anlage eine Anschuldigung die auch en
betraf der dem Staatssekretariat
geholfen haben soll die wahre Herkunft
des Geldes zu verschleiern indem er sich
die zu investierende Summe bei den
Banken geliehen und das Geld aus dem
peterspfennig verpfendet
[Musik]
hat das war das Geld das für wohltätige
Zwecke verwendet werden sollte das war
das Geld aus dem
peterspfennig aber sie haben es den
Vermögensverwalter nicht gesagt Sie
haben uns nicht gesagt dass die Gelder
für wohltätige Zwecke sind ich weiß
nicht ob den Banken gesagt wurde dass
sie mit dem Geld d kamen vorsichtig
umgehen sollten dass es nur für
wohltätige Zwecke verwaltet werden
durfte nein denn sonst hätten die Banken
keine Operation durchgeführt aber ich
würde gerne wissen warum stellen Sie mir
diese
Frage mit dem Auftrag den er erhalten
hatte musste Enrico crasso das Geschäft
auf Machbarkeit überprüfen weil er aber
keine Erfahrung im Ölsektor hatte suchte
er nach einem
[Musik]
Experten
ich sagte ihm eure Exzellenz meine
Erfahrung ist finanzieller Natur ich
kann Ihnen natürlich helfen aber was den
technischen Teil angeht muss ich Ihnen
sagen dass ich mich mit meiner Bank in
Verbindung setzen werde er sagte ja ja
bleiben Sie ganz ruhig verhalten sie
sich sehr diskret wir müssen es nicht
tun wenn es machbar ist wenn es
interessant ist und alle Kriterien
erfüllt sind werden wir es machen
ansonsten
[Musik]
nicht
eente s
rivolto nun ich wies darauf hin dass ich
zu der Bank gehen würde mit der ich
arbeite und so weiter und die kedit SS
ri mir nach London zu gehen wo ich mit
der minchone Gruppe bekannt gemacht
wurde die Experten auf dem
gebietemit Tate im my Figur
auf ein internationaler finan
italienischer Abstammung der in London
maand und Luxemburg tätig
war sie haben RA zum ersten Mal in
London getroffen was war ihr Eindruck
von
ihm er schien ein Experte zu sein er
erzählte mir dass er aus einer
zerrütteten Familie stammt sein Vater
hatte einige
Schwierigkeiten zog nach London und
gründete von dort aus ein
Unternehmen er sagte er habe ein enges
Verhältnis mit der enigruppe die Bank
habe mit ihm in London Geschäfte gemacht
er meinte also wenn derjenige der ihn
mir vorgestellt hat ihm vertraut müsse
ich mir keine Sorgen
machen dann hat er ihnen den Kardinal
vorgestellt nehme ich
an das habe
ich
nachdem Sie die Zustimmung von Kardinal
Angelo becio erhalten hatten machten
sich rafaele mincione und Enrico crasso
an die Arbeit um die technische und
finanzielle machtbarkeit der Investition
zu prüfen in der Zwischenzeit wurden die
200 Millionen die für die Investition
vorgesehen waren umgehend auf einen Fond
im Besitz von Raffaele minone übertragen
doch nach einem Jahr der Studien und
Bewertungen gaben die beiden Finanziers
ein negatives Urteil und rieeten von dem
Geschäft ab
nahm es zur Kenntnis breitete die Arme
aus wie es üblich ist und rührte keinen
Finger es wollte er sagen mal sehen
machen wir es und damit war alles zu
Ende denn die Operation wurde nicht
[Musik]
fortgeführt
im Staatssekretariat herrscht heute
große Unruhe es ist der 7 juni 2013 und
soeben ist ein Bericht aus luganu
eingetroffen der einen dunklen Schatten
auf die Figur von Raffaele minone
wirft es handelt sich um einen Artikel
aus der Wochenzeitung ilmondo den dieit
an den Schatzmeister des Sekretariats
fabrio und J perlaska die rechte Hand
von Erzbischof Angelo becio geschickt
hat in dem Artikel steht dass einige
italienische Abgeordnete nach dem
Versuch des Finanziers die Banka
populare die Milano zu übernehmen
parlamentarische Anfragen gestellt haben
um sich über die Undurchsichtigkeit der
Finanzströme seines Unternehmens und
über die Schwierigkeit die Herkunft
seiner finanziellen Mittel zu
rechtfertigen zu
[Musik]
beschweren
hallo ja Herr
tiabassi ein Bericht der ernst genommen
werden muss ist es möglich dass niemand
im Sekretariat diesen Verdachtsfällen
nachgegangen ist ich wollte wissen wie
sie zum Fall des Vatikans
stehen ich halte mich an meine
berufliche Schweigepflicht weil ich
immer noch einamter des Heil stuhs bin
kann ich keine interviewsben ich
danür mich gewandt haben
aber kein Kommentar auch von Monsignore
perlaska die Gerichtsdokumente zeigen
jedoch dass sich die Beziehung zwischen
dem Staatssekretariat und rafaele menone
trotz dieser dunklen Schatten sogar noch
verstärkt
hat hat der Kontakt zwischen rafaele
minone und dem Staatssekretariat
gehalten ja es wurde ein Kontakt
hergestellt und damit die Möglichkeit
das Vertrauen des Kunden zu gewinnen
und das hat er
geschafft er schlug eine weitere
Investition vor und sie stimmten
zu wir schreiben den juli 2014 ein
zentraler Moment in dieser Geschichte
als das Staatssekretariat beschließt die
Idee in die Ölquelle in Angola zu
investieren endgültig aufzugeben und
sein Interesse auf ein anderes
Unternehmen zu
richten Schug vor ein Gebäude in London
zu kaufen das alte Kaufhaus harrit das
einer seiner Firmen gehörte das Projekt
wurde sofort von Fabrizio tirabassi und
monsore perlaska
befürwortet discorso del palazzo stato
presentato un investimento super
conveniente la logica era che stavano
pagando
qu der Kauf des Gebäudes wurde als eine
sehr günstige Investition
dargestellt
die Logik war dass sie für etwas
bezahlten das weit unter seinem
Marktwert lag er lag 30 bis 40% unter
dem was sie mit dem Verkauf oder sogar
mit der Renovierung hätten erzielen
können weil es eine Art Baugenehmigung
gab die die Erhöhung und den Bau
erlaubte es würde eine große
Immobilieninvestition werden es ist ein
wunderschönes Gebäude das alte Kaufhaus
harits in London ein Trophy asset wie
man es
nennt und so einigen sich die Parteien
darauf wie die 200 Millionen Dollar
investiert werden sollen die das
Staatssekretariat bereits anvertraut
hatte und die in seinen Athena
Investmentfond geflossen
waren 100 Millionen Dollar wurden für
den Kauf von 45% der Anteile an dem
Londoner Gebäude bereitgestellt das dem
Minion Fond
gehörte der Rest wurde in
Finanzinstrumente desselben Athena Fond
Inv sie eigentmer des Gebäudes sondern
Besitzer von fondanteilen die
Vereinbarungen sahen vor dass die
anderen liquiden Mittel in vereinbarten
Finanzinstrumenten angelegt werden
sollten
aber aber hatte als Vermögensverwalter
gehandelt und sie so eingesetzt wie er
es eben
tat der Vatikan war also nicht der
direkte Eigentümer des Gebäudes sonder
nur Besitzer
vonondanteilen den Richtern
zufolte großen Verlust für den Heiligen
Stuhl indem er die verbleibenden 100
Millionen in Finanzinstrumente von
Unternehmen die mit ihm verbunden sind
oder auf jeden Fall in spekulative und
illiquide Finanzinstrumente
[Musik]
investierte man darf nicht vergessen
dass es an den Finanzmärkten nach 2008
immer weiter nach oben
ging wenn der liquiditätsanteil also ich
will nicht sagen umsichtig aber
gewissenhaft verwaltet worden wäre wären
die Erträge höchstwahrscheinlich höher
gewesen als die
Verwaltungsgebühren aber stattdessen
schrieb der Athener Fond tiefrote Zahlen
und verbrannte in 5 Jahren 18 Millionen
Euro wie die Berechnungen der pästlichen
Justiz zeigen aber nicht nur das für die
Durchführung dieser Operationen die zu
dem wirtschaftlichen disaster führten
hätte der Fond von im statsekretariat
weitere 18 Millionen Euro an Provisionen
in Rechnung
gestellt guten Morgen Ich suche Mr
minone er ist nicht hier um wie viel Uhr
kommt er wieder er kommt nicht er ist
nicht hier aber wohnt er
[Musik]
hier fen uns also wieder einmal im
Herzen der Schweiz in cherina nur einen
Steinwurf von St Moritz entfernt hier
ist der Finanzier offiziell gemeldet
aber wir treffen nur einen seiner
Bediensteten an keine Spur von
[Musik]
ihm nein nein er war in den letzten
Monaten wegen des Coronavirus da aber
normalerweise wohnt er nicht
hier mir ist bekannt dass er in cherina
wohnhaft war
[Musik]
so steht es in den Unterlagen der
Staatsanwaltschaft der Finanzier hat
außerdem große Interessen in der Schweiz
nicht nur weil einige seiner Unternehmen
dort ansässig sind sondern auch weil er
Miteigentümer des legendären Hotel Palas
in St Moritz ist wir hätten also gerne
seine Seite der Geschichte erfahren
zumal die Ermittler Minion selbst als
die Person bezeichnen die am meisten von
dem Londoner Missgeschick des Heiligen
Stuhls profitiert
hätte
amonich
[Musik]
Haushälterin erklären Sie ihm dass es
besser wäre wenn er mir ein Interview
gibt wenn er sich dafür zur Verfügung
stellt kann er mir sagen wie seine
Position
ist weil sich herausgestellt hat dass er
viele Millionen abgezweigt
hat ich weiß ich weiß es
ist sumen entziehen sich
Normalsterblichen das ist die
Schwierigkeit die ich oft habe wenn ich
sie nenne und den Lesern davon
erzähle anhand der Wege die dieses Geld
genommen hat können wir ableiten wie
sehr nicht nur der Wille der Spender
sondern auch der Wille des Papstes
verraten wurde wir können also davon
ausgehen dass es das Ziel des Papstes
ist das Geld wieder zuuerlangen und vor
allem die Schuldigen innerhalb des
Heiligen Stuhls zu
bestrafen
es war im Mai 2018 als etwas bizarres
geschah der Papst erhob Erzbischof
Angelo beo in den Rang eines Kardinals
und ernannte ihn zum Präfekten der
Kongregation für die selig und
Heiligsprechungen es mag wie eine
Beförderung erscheinen aber in
Wirklichkeit das sagen viele Leute im
Vatikan war der einzige Zweck dieser
Geste Angelo beo von der Leitung des
staatssekretariats zu
entfernen
im Vatikan herrschte bereits eine
wachsende Verlegenheit über die
Situation die durch diese verlustreiche
Investition entstanden war und man war
sich nicht einig darüber was zu tun
[Musik]
sei
hallo sind sie stadat
villone der Anwalt von Kardinal
be nun ich rufe sie an weil ich sie um
eine Stellungnahme oder ein Interview
bitten wollte wir hätten gerne von der
betroffenen Person gewusst warum sie
ausgerechnet das Geld das dem Papst von
den Gläubigen angeboten wurde in ein so
obskures und spekulatives Geschäft
investieren wollte doch seine Eminenz
lehnte jeden kommmentar ab will er
nichts dazu
sagen eine Sache die Sie tun sollten und
das habe ich schon im Februar 2017
gesagt ist die Rückerstattung zu
bekommen eine Lösung zu finden aber vor
allem eine Bewertung der Immobilie
vorzunehmen mit wem haben Sie gesprochen
ich habe an Monsignore perlaska und
Herrn tirabassi geschrieben und was
haben sie geantwortet sie haben nicht
geantwortet tatsächlich beschlossen die
Leiter des Sekretariats erst im November
2018 nach dem Abgang von Kardinal bechu
den Fond von rafaele Minion zu verlassen
allerdings mit dem Ziel das gesamte
Gebäude in London zu kaufen an dem sie
bereits 45% der Anteile besaßen sie
konnten sich jedoch nicht mit dem
Finanzier
einigen und in diesem Moment betritt ein
neuer Akteur ebenfalls aus London die
Bühne unseres Rollenspiels ein weiterer
Makler mit italienischen
[Musik]
Wurzeln Herr torzi wurde gebeten ein
Problem zu lösen das das
Staatssekretariat zu dieser Zeit hatte
es war ein ziemlich dringendes
Problem es ging darum ein Weg zu finden
der es dem Staatssekretariat ermöglichte
das Eigentum an der Immobilie wieder zuu
erlangen her torzi identifizierte sich
damit aus vielerlei Gründen abgesehen
von seinen eigenen beruflichen
Fähigkeiten kannte er vor allem Herrn
Minion
gut torzi wurde als Lösung präsentiert
um aus dem Deal mit Minion
herauszuommen er sagte er derjenige se
der minchone davon überzeugen könne das
Gebäude
aufzugeben nun er sagte dass minchone
den er sehr gut kannte wegen der
Geschäftsbeziehungen die sie hatten und
die er manchmal mit seinen Firmen
finanzierte nicht nein sagen konnte ich
war jedoch ein wenig skeptisch was die
Tatsache betraf dass torzi minchone
finanziert
hat in Wirklichkeit aber traf torzi in
Wirklichkeit hat torzi dann minchone
davon überzeugt das Gebäude zu
verkaufen er b um einen Termin im
Sekretariat und unterbreitete Alka und
tii einen
Vorschlag sehen Sie ich habe schone
davon überzeugt und das zu diesem Preis
er wäre bereit das Gebäude zu
verkaufen 40 Millionen
Pfund das ist die Summe auf die sich die
beiden italienischenglischen Geldgeber
geeinigt haben und die Tor dem Vatikan
überreicht eine beachtliche Zahl die
nach Ansicht derlichen Justiz jeder
relichen und wirschlich zu Enten
schint vor allem wenn man bedenkt dass
das Sekretariat bereits 200 Millionen
Dollar in den Fond von rafaele minone
eingezahlt hatte und dass die Immobilie
mit einem Teil der Kosten belastet war
tatsächlich gab der Vatikan
363 Millionen Euro für ein Gebäude aus
das Raffaele menone 6 Jahre zuvor für
weniger als die Hälfte dieser Summe
erworben
hatte
40 Millionen wie kamen diese 40
Millionen für Mr m
zusammen offensichtlich sind die 40
Millionen nicht auf Initiative von Herrn
torzi zustande gekommen in dem Sinne
dass natürlich auch das
Staatssekretariat ein klares Interesse
an der Schadensminimierung gezeigt hat
das liegt auf der Hand offensichtlich
hation auf ein für ihn sicherlich sehr
wichtiges Geschäft verzichtet angesichts
einer
gen sein musste um das staatsekretariat
zurück in den Besitz der Immobilie
bringen zu
können waren sie etwas
überrascht sehen Sie wir waren ein wenig
überrascht aber wissen Sie wenn der
Kunde zufrieden
ist ich war erstaunt darüber wie leicht
es war für etwas eine Lösung in bis 7
Tagen zu finden und dass ich seit dem 17
januar 2017 gebankt hatte
gen
201 aber wer ist die Person die den
Vatikan innerhalb weniger Tage aus der
brdulie zu bringen
[Musik]
schien darüber haben wir neich erst
gesprochen weil ich es selbst wissen
wollte glücklich darüber er sagte nein
ich hatte einfach Glück ich es geschafft
habe in Kreise zu gelangen an die ich
nicht mal zu träumen gewagt
[Musik]
hätteanuigi wuch in gonesi einer kleinen
Stadt in moliss auf und besuchte die
Schule für
Landwirtschaft sein Vater Enrico hatte
ein Getreidelager und stellte
Düngemittel
her ihr Familienunternehmen
ihr Familienunternehmen
ja und weil er es gewohnt war auf
mehreren Hochzeiten zu tanzen gründete
er zur gleichen Zeit ein weiteres
Unternehmen im Bereich
Wasseraufbereitung was ist aus diesen
beiden Unternehmen
geworden nichts beide sind bankrott
gegangen leider das Leben seiner Familie
verkompliziert und Schulden gemacht die
dann zum Bankrott
führten von Düngemitteln zum Tempel des
Herrn durch verschiedene familire
Misserfolge hindurch so begannanigi Tor
Karriere und führte ihn nach London
mitten ins Herz der
Stadt er ist nicht der klassische
italienerus ein kinad London geht und
dort zunächst einmal als Tellerwäscher
anfängt nein er ging mit einem
Unternehmen dorthin das bereit war auf
dem Markt
mitzumischen einen solchen Sprung von
einer kleinen Stadt in Molise und von
der Produktion von Düngemitteln hin zur
Verwaltung internationale Fonds schafft
man nicht einfach nur weil man gut daran
ist wie ist
dekommen ist das Nervenzentrum der
römischatholischen beweg und Befreiung
in
[Musik]
moliss es gibt dort eine sehr starke
Gemeinschaft höchstwahrscheinlich
ergaben sich die Verbindungen zum
Vatikan direkt aus der Bewegung auch
weil einer der Beteiligten der Bewegung
sehr sehr nahe
stand der Unternehmer aus Molise kommt
also an die Schwelle des Heiligen Stuhls
um den Streit um das Londoner Gebäude zu
schlichten doch zu diesem Zeitpunkt war
dieser umstrittene Manager bereits durch
einen rechtlichen Zwischenfall mit
verstörenden Grundzügen in molisse
vorbelastet dieani
[Musik]
torzi wir sprechen von Gian Luigi torzi
der uns geschadet hat sagen wir mal
betrogen um das richtige Wort zu
benutzen den zunchst trat er an uns
heran als Freund der helfen wollte der
etwas tun wollte kurz gesagt er
entpuppte sich als Judas er hat uns
eigentlich um alles
betrogen wir befinden uns in Termoli
Molise im Jahr 2010 hat die
Wirtschaftskrise die Familie varanese an
den Rand der wirtschaftlichen
Katastrophe getrieben die Geschäfte der
Kinder gehen in Konkurs und als sie in
die Enge getrieben werden beschließen
sie mit gianigi torzi einen Deal
einzugehen und ein Touristendorf zu
bauen sie würden die Familienvilla am
Meer und das Land mitbringen der
Finanzier das
Kapital die Villa hatte einen
Handelswert von 1 Million und 2 1lion
300000€ fürior war alles ein Spiel sag
er würde einen fiktiven Kaufvertrag
aufsetzen indem wir den Verkaufspreis
der Immobilie auf
320000€ setzen so würden wir auch
weniger Steuern zahlen danach würden wir
anfangen zu bauen und alles so
machen und das wurde uns im Grunde zum
Verhängnis die Firma in der dieses
familienjuwel gelandet ist ist Eigentum
von Tor und nicht von
Marell hat keine Baugenehmigung erhalten
und wurde nie gebaut so verlor die
Familie varanesse ihre schöne Villa am
Meer von einem Tag auf den anderen sahen
wir uns praktisch von unserem Grundstück
verdrängt raus mit nichts einfach so
wirstatteten Anzeige bei der
Finanzaufsicht ich habe ihnen gezeigt
dass ich auf Schwindel hereingefallen
bin auf einen Betrug der Beamte drehte
sich um sah mich an und sagte her kion
sehen Sie diesen Stapel und er zeigte
mir einen Stapel von Aktenordnern 60 70
cm hoch auf einem Schreibtisch das sagte
der Beamte und sah mir dabei sehr ernst
in die Augen ist alles von gianluigi
[Musik]
torziior seitdem fordert die Familie
Gerechtigkeit und sie ist nicht allein
in der Tat gibt es viele offene
Verfahren gegen den Unternehmer einige
sogar vor seinem Eintritt in den Vatikan
gegenwärtig
Justiz wegen einer Vielzahl von
Straftaten in Rom Mailand Bari und
larino an wo im Dezember 2020 eine erste
Anhörung zu einer Angelegenheit
stattfand die mit der Villa der Familie
verbunden
war seine ver v besestüis
zumusfed ung zu
Verbrechen was haben sie dann irgendwann
beschlossen zu
tun ich bin plötzlich drauf gekommen dem
Papst zu schreiben und ihm kurz unsere
Situation zu
schildern möchten Sie Vorlesen was Sie
geschrieben haben soll ich es
[Musik]
vorlesen genautig wiren uns in einer
Situation wieder in der uns alles
genommen wurde ohne dass wir es merkten
denn alles wurde von einer liebevollen
Fürsorge verschleiert eine brüderliche
Hand bot uns an uns aus einer
schwerwiegenden wirtschaftlichen Lage zu
[Musik]
befreien mit der Zeit wurde uns klar
dass es eine gelinde gesagt fragwürdige
Art war uns das Grundstück in
entreißen es ist der zweite
Weihnachtsfeiertag 2018 als etwas
Außergewöhnliches passiert der Papst
gewährtanigi torzi eine
Privataudienz wir wissen nicht worüber
sie gesprochen haben aber sicher ist
dieses Treffen ist zentral für das
Verständnis der weiteren Entwicklungen
offenbar hatemand der dem Papst sehr nah
steht ihm den finan Retter des Londoner
Gebäudes
[Musik]
vorgestellt zu diesem Zeitpunkt war er
Katholik Sowi Herr torzi auch der den
Heiligen Vater besucht hat der für
Katholiken ja das höchste religiöse
Oberhaupt der Welt
ist ich kann ihen sagen dass er
sichtlich bewegt war als er von der
Begegnung mit dem Heiligen Vater
erzählte er sagte mir weißt du dass ich
heute Nachmittag in den Vatikan zum
Heiligen Vater gehen muss ich sagte
Glückwunsch gut aber weißt du ich weiß
nicht ob ich gehen soll was soll das
heißen Du weißt nicht ob du gehen sollst
ich meine das ist doch so eine schöne
Sache was sagst du redst du mir zu gehen
es war wirklich
absurd kann man also sagen dass Herr
torzi innerhalb des watikans unantastbar
geworden
war nein sagen wir eher er hat ein
Problem gelöst aber ein anderes
geschaffen tatsächlich ging das Gebäude
nicht direkt von rafaele meniones Athena
an den Vatikan sondern landete bei einer
Firma namens gut die Gian Luigi torzi
gehörte g die Vereinbarung sah vor dass
das Staatssekretariat in der
Zwischenzeit eine spezielle Gesellschaft
für das Londoner Gebäude und dann für
den Makler aus Molise gründen würde die
Aktien verkaufen würde das geschah aber
nicht
als sie diesen Vertrag erhielten
stellten sie fest dass 1000 Aktien der
Stimmrechtsanteil bei torzi verbleiben
ich wusste das nicht
einmal das heißt die Aktien mit
Stimmrecht genau und der Vatikan konnte
also nichts mit diesem Gebäude
anfangen sagen wir er war der Eigentümer
aber verwaltet hat es wer
stimmberechtigt war wenn Sie mich fragen
wenn er es am nächsten Tag für 10000
oder 10 Millionen pund hätte verkaufen
können er das getan aber war dem Vatikan
ihrer Meinung nach klar dass er ein
Gebäude kaufte an dem er keine Rechte
hatte nein nein ich schließe das völlig
[Musik]
aus bei diesem Treffen sagte Tor ich
werde dafür sorgen dass sie das Gebäude
zurückerhalten monsore peraska ließ ih
reden und nach einer we sagte er hören
Sie was bringen diese000 Aktien haben
wir kein
stimmenrecht erkannten sie es ich habe
diesen Vertrag auch nie
gesehen ja wir sind auf dem
Weg wir nehmen die nächste
ausfahr im Heiligen Stuhl gibt es jedoch
Stimmen die behaupten dass die
Bedingungen des Vertrages wohl beeknt
waren dies wir von einem hsträger des
Kirchenstaates best der einem
treffentim
ja das ist er stell hier links von ihm
abke
hier der Vertrag den sie mit T
unterschrieben haben er gibt keinen Sinn
er macht keinen Sinn ich habe ihn
gesehen es stand schwarz auf weiß
geschrieben dass die Aktien alle Aktien
mit Stimmrecht an gehen würdenähr der
heilige ohne Stimmrecht
BEK es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten entweder
war jemand zu naiv oder sie waren
böswillig und haben viel Geld dafür
genommen wenn man einen Vertrag nicht
verstehen kann geht man zu einem Anwalt
richtig aber nein nein sie haben einfach
unterschrieben es ist 2018 als der neue
Stellvertreter für Allgemeine
Angelegenheiten monsore Edgar Pen der
Angelo beo abgelöst hat die Operation
gut heizt die sich in wenigen Tagen als
kolossaler Fehler erweisen
[Musik]
wird er hat also in der Tat die volle
Kontrolle über dieses Gebäude obwohl er
keinen Cent hineingesteckt hat als der
Vatikan nach ein paar Wochen beschließt
auch torzi zu liquidieren sagt Tor ich
habe diese Anteile jetzt müssen sie mir
meine Provision bezahlen sonst gebe ich
diese Anteile nicht zurück diese Aktien
ermöglichten esorzi in der Tat das
Gebäude unter seiner Gewalt zu haben und
damit 200 Millionen des Vatikans in
seinen Händen zu
halten wir kommen also zum Epilog zum
verabscheuungswürdigsten Verbrechen das
von den Richtern angenommen wurde die
Erpressung des
Vatikans verlangte vom Heiligen Stuhl
zunächst sogar 20 Millionen EUR nach
mühsamen Verhandlungen auf 15 Millionen
Euro
runterzugehen ich glaube nicht dass
diese Zahlung das Ergebnis einer
Erpressung ist aber es ist eine Zahlung
die offensichtlich mit einem Vorgang
verbunden sein
muss die Wahl Bestand einerseits darin
dem Sekretariat zu ermöglichen das
Eigentum an der Immobilie
wiederzuerlangen und andererseits ist
der Firma von Herr torzi durch 1000
stimmberechtigte Aktien zu ermöglichen
diese Immobilie 5 Jahre zu verwalten her
torzi hat man gesagt er solle sich aus
diesem Geschäft zurückziehen und deshalb
sind 15 Millionen vielleicht eine
angemessene Entschädigung für das was
man getan und Herrn torzi offensichtlich
in Bezug auf die Verwaltung einer
Immobilie genommen
hatispetto alla gestione
immobile hatte mir anvertraut dass er
ein Problem hatte weil Tor sich aufgrund
dieses Vertrages berechtigt fühlte 20
Millionen zu verlangen um die Aktien mit
Stimmrecht zu verkaufen und das
Unternehmen zu verlassen penap kam zu
mir um mir das mitzuteilen und ich sagte
ihm mit einigem Nachdruck bezahlen Sie
ihn nicht bezahlen Sie ihn
nicht aber das statssekretariat gibt
nach es beginnt eine fieberhafte Suche
nach Geld bis Monsignore perlaska
Monsignore par eine Lösung vorschlägt
das Geld für die Bezahlung von torzi
soll vom diskretionskonto des Papstes
genommen werden ein Konto das nur dem
Heiligen Vater zur Verfügung steht das
entgegen jeder Logik nicht beim ior der
Vatikanbank sondern bei einer Schweizer
Bank
liegt proro di
luganoffici
fuciarioes genau hier im Zentrum von
Lugano befindet sich das Büro eines Tess
Treuhänders der das 2015 bei der
ubsingerete to Papstes verwaltet und von
diesem Konto hätte der tessina
Treuhänder laut monsore perlaska 20
Millionen pund abheben müssen um die
Forderungen von gianluigi torzi zu
erfüllen die Anweisungen die nach Lugano
geschickt wurden waren sehr präzise 12
Millionen Pfund sollten abgehoben werden
und es sollte ein Überziehungskredit von
weiteren 8 Millionen Pfund beantragt
wden h gerne getroffen aber aus Gründen
der Diskretion verweigerte er ein
Interview wir wissen also nicht ob das
Konto des Papstes betroffen ist sicher
ist dass nach Angaben der Justiz in
jenen Tagen 20 Millionen Euro auf einem
Konto der vatikananwälte in London
eingegangen sind und mit diesem Geld
wird gianigi Tor bezahlt mit zwei
Überweisungen in Höhe von insgesamt 15
Millionen
EUR
doch damit ist die Geschichte noch nicht
zu Ende Justiz vermutet dass torzi nicht
allein gehandelt
hat ich habe dir mein vollstes Vertrauen
geschenkt weil du mir den Arsch gerettet
hast aber Fabri ich will bezahlt werden
ich gehe nicht einfach so gib mir 10
Millionen und ich gehe was zum Teufel
soll ich dir
[Musik]
sagen es ist der 19 dezember 2018 die
Lage hat sich verschlechtert und in
einem Hotel in Mailand findet eine Art
Gipfeltreffen statt um torzi davon zu
überzeugen die 1us Aktien zu verkaufen
aber die Männer des Vatikans trauen
niemandem mehr und jemand zeichnet das
Gespräch
auf selbst wenn sie mir 10 Millionen
geben ich habe ihm eine Million gezahlt
was denken Sie er hat mich am Abend
vorher angerufen ich habe die
Überweisung hier ich erzähle keinen
Scheiß verstehen sie er rief mich am
Abend vorher an und sagte das ist mein
Konto bei der
UBS was ist wirklich passiert er sagt
wörtlich gibt mir 8 Millionen gibt mir
10 Millionen von denen ich drei übrig
habe weil ich die anderen mit
Schmiergeldern bezahlt
habe glauben Sie nicht dass das
vielleicht nur Angeberei
war im Eifer des Gefechts wäre das eine
einfache Möglichkeit ein einfacher Weg
die Situation aufzulösen klar ist es
gibt dafür keine
Beweise diemler des Vatikans versuchen
herauszufinden ob dieses Geld komplett
an torzi ging oder ob ein Teil dieses
Geldes tatsächlich an Beamte und
Monsignore innerhalb des Vatikans
ging deshalb versuchen Sie
herauszufinden ob es intern Korruption
gibt die irgendwie erklärt warum
Knebelverträge abgeschlossen wur zum
Nachteil vatians und zum Vorteil der
weltlichen
Geldgeber es ist der 25 September 2020
als Angelo beo der vom Skandal um das
Londoner Gebäude und einer Reihe anderer
juristischer Vorfälle überwältigt wurde
vom Heiligen Vater vorgeladen
wird der hat mir gesagt dass er mir
nicht mehr traut weil er einen Bericht
von den Richtern bekommen habe dass ich
Gelder veruntreut haben soll ich habe
dem Heiligen Vater gesagt wenn er mir
nicht mehr vertraut gebe ich mein Mandat
auf dann trete ich zurück das
[Musik]
war's seit gestern verzichtet der
Kardinal auf die mit dem Amt verbundenen
Rechte und wird nicht an der
pontifexwahl teilnehmen können ich fühle
mich nicht korrumpiert sagte
er die in dieser Untersuchung vermuteten
Verbrechen sind Korruption Veruntreuung
Geldwäsche sogar Erpressung und die
Bildung einer kriminellen Vereinigung
Gian Luigi torzi wurde sogar verhaftet
und kam ins vatikanische Gefängnis 10
Tage lang mit Hilfe eines
Rechtshilfeersuchens an die Schweizer
Behörden forderte die Staatsanwaltschaft
des Heiligen Stuhls die Herausgabe der
Bankverbindungen und Salden der Konten
von Kardinal beo monsore
und and in Ermangelung eines Urteils
gilt derzeit für alle die
Unschuldsvermutung es wird gegen sie
ermittelt sie werden beschuldigt mit T
kooperiert zu haben aber ich denke wegen
der
Verschwörung wegen
Erpressung und das ist was mich am
meistenrübt als die Person genannt die
am meisten von diesem Londoner
Bauvorhaben profitieren
sollte ja so verstehe ich es auch mit
torzi und nein nein nein nicht im
geringsten für Enrico crasso kommt der
Ärger nicht nur aus dem Vatikan auch in
der Schweiz setzt ihn die Justiz unter
Druck wegen der Geschäfte mit seinem
zenturion Investmentfond in den das
Staatssekretariat rund 50 Millionen EUR
investiert hat eine weitere Geschichte
die sich zu einer Kriminalgeschichte
Vatikan entwickelt hat dunkle Zeiten für
den Bankier Gottes der nur noch auf
Gerechtigkeit warten
kann es stimmt dass ich besorgt bin aber
ich habe keine Angst ich habe Mitleid
mit meinen Kindern mit meinen
Enkelkindern das ist etwas was ich nicht
erwartet habe ich hatte gehofft dass sie
sich auf andere Weise an ihren Großvater
erinnern würden nicht wegen dieses
wirklich unglaublichen Unsinns wissen
Sie wie sich das anfühlt es ist als
würde man mit einem men zusammenarbeiten
ihm helfen und dann dreht man sich
irgendwann um und wird hinterrück
zerstochen so fühlt sich das an
[Musik]
Sensation
FE
stream